occupation en cours d'un immeuble à
paris par le collectif réquisitions
notamment une action coup de poing pour
mettre à l'abri 150 personnes
demandeuses d'asile vivent actuellement
dans la rue les manifestants se sont
réunis dans unique dans une école
maternelle aujourd'hui inoccupés
les travaux pour la transformer en
logements sont prévus mais bloquée
judiciairement au micro de nicolas
couper la sénatrice esther benbassa le
député eric coquerel se disent
solidaires avec le mouvement
cette action c'est pour pouvoir loger
des migrants qui sont difficiles à des
mois dans les ronds même les bleus dès
lors en novembre qui s'étaient réunis à
la halle j'ai pu blique n'ont pas été
illogique en revanche à tous nos voeux
j'ai encore alors cette action c'est un
acte de printemps le gouvernement
un accueil pas et les noix grande comme
il se doit et une occupation social de
ce logement de réquisition citoyenne
parce que c'est l'état qui devrait être
qu'ils devraient réquisitionné ici ces
logements pour faire en sorte que les
gens qui sont en train de dormir dans la
rue suite à l'évacuation des campements
de saint denis ya plusieurs semaines de
cela puisse trouver un abri dont c'est
important de venir ce qui les
associations les gens qui occupent pour
que
on arrête on arrête un peu avec ce que
ce scandale absolu qui est qu en plein
hiver il ya des gens qui sont laissés
sur les trottoirs par l'état mais seules
les associations collectifs citoyens
sont de plus voilà ils vont s'en occuper
ici et j'espère que pendant au mois
quelques mois ça va leur servir de
refuge